so tell your
friends all right once again Griffin
with Griffin is live on a special day
let's
go ladies and
gentlemen coming in
early with your favorite
podcast
yeah
feel
W what's up y'all I am going out of town
starting tomorrow so I had to do the
podcast early so here we are I'm
actually going to be on the road with
Matt R I'm going to be uh from Wednesday
to Sunday in the Ohio area so no way to
get tickets because it's already sold
out but I'm also going today be talking
about my Britney Spears update we got to
check in on Britney Candace Owens went
in on some students no more Skittles in
California and my fast X spoiler
[Music]
[Applause]
recap what's up everybody Welcome to
riffin with Griffin I know we on a
special time we doing it early week
early early early well not too early
just instead of tomorrow I'm doing it
today CU I got to go out of town so if
you're catching it live right now cool
because when the stream finishes I'm
going to take it offline and then put it
then uh do it put it back on so if
you're here now great for you you get an
early access but tomorrow it will be
after this I'll take it off and then you
know schedule it to come back on
tomorrow but anyways um what's going on
today uh on the podcast first I want to
I want to thank everybody for watching
so please you know what helps is when
you subscribe hit that subscribe button
so you get those notifications so you
can see what's going on I'm on Twitch on
most days even when I'm on the road I
find I I sign in and I twitch and if you
want to support the show there you can
be a YouTube member you could be a um a
twitch subscriber that helps support me
and you can also be a patreon member and
I know it's like I feel like I'm
slipping on my patreon but it's coming I
always say it but you know it is I just
got to get past all this business and
then it's just going to
be patreon's going to be like probably
be going to be all baby stuff keep
keeping up with the baby right but uh
welcome back welcome to riffing with
Griffon you know um yeah guys uh thank
thanks uh for being here once again I
got to get a new chair my chair broke so
I'm like I'm actually it's crazy but I'm
actually leaning to the left here
because of my chair might just fall and
break my break my face trying to do this
but yeah man um I'm I'm here this week
early like I
said because I'm going out of town
tomorrow and I was like I don't want to
miss another podcast episode just
because I've been so busy it's
crazy but let's see so let me give you
some updates let me give you some
updates on what's been going on so as
you know from last week about my car
situation so yeah man you know I feel
like now that I think about it even more
feel like the $5,000 was stolen from me
I think it's horrible business practice
by Fisker to have a
nonrefundable uh that that's it's crazy
especially with the customer service the
way it is so so I don't know who knows
what I'll think in three years what I'm
going to do but I'm actually getting a
lucid guys I'm getting a lucid air I am
going to get that uh so I'm I'm excited
about that but I'm you there's there's
situations with every every company
right CU I real so like I was supposed
to get my car on Monday and then you
know I F I have all my paperwork filled
out I have all the stuff filled
out right uh come to find out she's like
the lady hits me up and she's like oh my
God Eric I'm so sorry but your car is
still in Arizona cuz they have a
manufacturing plant in Arizona your
car's still there and I'm like what I
thought it was going to be here by
Monday I already sold my other car so
now we just have a one car household uh
so if you and all you people listening
to thanks for listening every week on
whatever however you listen to it when
you get a chance go in and check out the
the the um what do you call it the
YouTube episode so but just for the
people watching right now special
look yeah baby that's what I'm getting
right there right there it's uh for you
people that are just listening right now
it's uh you know Lucid air touring it's
uh Stellar white metallic Tahoe interior
19in Arrow range Wheels Platinum with
glass canopy and dual motors all-wheel
drive woo love
it looking
fancy so yeah so that's happening so
we'll see what's going on um today on
today's episode there's going to be
spoilers The spoiler is I was I don't
know if you guys for the people that
watch the podcast regularly you guys
remember when I was on a plane and I
watched fast and of Furious 9 and it was
so ridiculous that I came on the podcast
and I recapped it from beginning to end
well guess what I saw 10 on a plane the
other day coming home from Boston and we
got a recap
part pret 10 it's this movie is
ridiculous okay anyways so look out for
that spoilers at this point it doesn't
even matter if you if you haven't seen
it yet it doesn't you if you if you're
into the Fast and Furious you probably
already seen it you know I mean it's
just the the movies are ridiculous okay
so I am going to uh go do a recap
towards the end here just from beginning
and end the whole freaking movie all
right so look out for that y'all
um all right so let's just get to
comments of the week man comments go to
the comment section if you'd like to
leave a comment please do leave a
comment
on um what do you call
it uh you know on YouTube right here I
should try to get go get some of those
apple music comments or comments from
other places but cuz I'm YouTube I'm
like I like to do the YouTube uh so you
know congrats uh so anyways let's see um
what we got here um
Marlene I think it's Marlin no no I
think it's Marlene something or other
it's like a long ass name thank you yes
director Griffin I myself have been
inspired recently through comedy I'm
teaching myself how to do my own pilot
etc etc no experience comed's giving me
life so thank you for that I'm not a but
I want to do the work and keep this
thing going so you know good luck you
know what I mean that's what I'll say to
that let me put a comment up right now
you got this okay so thanks for
watching uh Eric Monte mon
monota or Monch n n
9249 God I feel like such an old man
sometimes love you Griffin you're one of
the best I appreciate
that
um
let's see somebody said arrogant Savage
well that's a weird name he said damn
tried going back and watching old
episodes I missed didn't realize the
whole episode would be about coid I
don't think it was I don't think it was
the whole episode but all
right uh let's
see somebody
Jamie Jamie zinks 2838 said Jesus Christ
I'm listening to this on
mushrooms I hope it helps
ah let's see somebody uh let's see
Amber Amber Marley 3737 said also don't
tell the dying wife the doctor called
hope sleeping with the ex was worth it
yeah remember that episode where the guy
I was telling you about that the guy's
the wife's dying and she her request is
to sleep with her ex one last time you
know wow difficult situation huh um um
let's see what else we got
here uh people love watching that Bobby
Lee and and Steve Lee episode and
somebody fact short sand Moore said just
three good friends having conversation
that's usually what it
is that is usually what it
is all right but anyways thanks for your
comments guys I appreciate you guys
commenting every week let's see if that
means check in the the the live chat
here I put questions here somebody has a
no nobody has a question
have you been watching Big Brother it's
been good this year man I feel bad
because I actually haven't been watching
Big Brother so you everybody keeps
telling me about this so I'm actually G
to have to check in I have all like
there's like 17 episodes on my on my uh
DVR my YouTube TV that I that I haven't
watched so I guess I'm going to have to
just download like when I'm traveling on
a plane and just get me some big brother
in so you know what I promise I will get
caught up and start watching Big Brother
for those joining right now I am doing
this late on a Tuesday night 10 p.m.
Pacific time because I am going out of
town Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday and uh you know it's going to be
tough and speaking of speaking you guys
just remind me of that speaking of going
out of town speaking of going out of
town and doing comedy um guys guess what
I have some dates coming up I have a lot
of dates before the baby comes and so
let's get those in right now so
I'm going to be at the Dana Florida
improv October 20th and 21st and my
buddy Vincent osana is gonna from
Valiant
um they do that big sort of political
podcast all the time big podcast but and
he's just one of my best friends for
over 20 years he's going to be on the
show with me so come check that out in
Danel Florida October 20 and 21st I'll
be at the comedy zone Greenville October
27th and 28th one night at the Orlando
Improv November 2nd so if you're in
Orlando tell your friends let's get that
sold out and then I'll be in that same
weekend I'll be at Sid Splitters Tampa
Florida November 3rd and 4th and just
added and I don't have it on my website
right now but just added I'm going to be
at the stress Factory in New Jersey New
Brunswick New Jersey I'll be at the
stress Factory one night only
November 9th I believe it is November
9th yes November 9th is a Thursday at
the stress Factory because I'm I just
got a new directing job so U Martin
amini he's doing his special and I'm
going to direct that and that's going to
be and so I'm GNA be wa he's got the
week he's doing the weekend there so I
said well let me just see if I can get a
one night and then I'll be there for the
weekend watching him and like you know
we're going to start working on the do
the work to be done to get his special
done so you know director Griffin
working again but those are my dates
come check me out if you want to see me
live I am still hilarious so thanks for
that
people
um oh and I in the chat I see somebody
said mj2 have you watched and review
John Wick 4 I did watch John Wick 4 and
I believe I did review it already but
that's just a weird ass movie all right
so let's talk about what's going on in
in the world right now huh I'm just
going to go right into the riffing
topics
um let's just go right into the riffing
topics uh from this week okay so let's
see okay so oh I want to start this over
sucks let me just go back so I don't
know if you guys know who Candice Owens
is I don't know if you know who that is
I actually didn't know who Candace Owens
I mean I heard about her but it's like
I'm not it's not like I follow her all
that much but apparently she was uh
she's like you know a conservative
political comment commentator author
activist television presenter and
anytime somebody's of color and they're
like labeled as conservative that's like
controversial you know it's like oh if
it's a black woman who's Conservative
then it turns into this whole thing
right but you know she's pretty it's
pretty interesting I'm starting to
follow just to see what she's got going
on I mean I don't no matter what my
political leanings are I like to listen
to all sides you know I'm more I'm more
I'm more Center of of the extremes
anyway but any go anyways she's um
Candace goes to this school and she's
speaking at this school apparently I
don't know all the details but I'm just
going to uh you know uh add my own from
what I think's going on right so she's
at this school okay
and so here we go so Candace Owens is at
this school and she's obviously a a
speaker so this is what they do schools
bring someone like this in sometimes
they'll have like a a conservative
person a liberal person but she's a very
hot button she has a lot of
controversial opinions about things
about Trends about you know all kinds of
stuff that you would think you know that
gets clicks you know what I mean um you
know she's got strong opinions about
stuff so so she's at she's speaking live
this is her event at this college okay
and then this person asks this question
and I hope you guys can hear it cuz this
is what happened to the trans students
on this campus who feel actively
victimized by your presence here life's
tough get a helmet man I'm too pregnant
for
this okay
so she like goes in man you know so this
girl you know at at the Candace own
event Candice owens's event stands up
and says you know what do you think
about you know the trans students who
are actively triggered by your presence
and she responds life's tough get a
helmet all
right I have a lot of feelings about
this I have like I think this is like on
both sides of this that I have an
opinion okay first thing is
this if she scheduled to be at the
school at a college a place of learning
a place where ideas are supposed to be
shared a place where you know you're
supposed to actively challenge yourself
and the people around you you're
supposed to be challenged by teachers by
Thoughts by ideas things shouldn't be
silenced okay that's the first thing all
right so whoever whatever conservative
organization on campus that probably
asked her to come to the school to speak
to that that that are in line with her
beliefs they were like yeah come to our
school right right so she's there so
these kind of people show
up and they're like hey what you know
and she she responds
great sad part is only a black woman
could respond like this and it be like
not to say it's okay but it's not
getting like even more like if this was
some straight white male if this was
like you know an actor anybody a male at
all it's just this would have been just
like oh what are you doing you know it's
like so my thing is it wasn't a
surprise it'd be one thing if it was
like some liberal event and then Candace
Owens crashes it like yo what up
everybody I'm pregnant I'm here to talk
smack about gays and trans I mean then
it's like you go whoa whoa Whoa man
you're triggering us then you have a
point but like how are you gonna go to
her
thing and do and and try to make it out
of and that's and it's so crazy that the
girl she she has no response you know
what I mean she literally has what can
she say you know what I mean like what
can this person say you know what I mean
and she's just looking at her like wow
trans students on this campus you feel
actively victimized by your presence
here life's tough get a helmet man I'm
too pregnant for this you know what I
mean she's just like I'm too pregnant
for this man you know and and that girl
just like she has nothing to say cuz
it's like that's how you supposed to
respond to someone like that
look I'm all for sensitivities
everybody's sensitive you know I'm not
one of these people that's like you know
people are too sensitive right now like
young people are too sensitive I feel
like sensitive people change the world
you know an acting teacher told me that
one time sensitive people change the
world so I don't mind that you're
sensitive what I do mind is how we deal
with people's Sensitivity I mind that
the fact that people think that because
they're sensitive we have to change
everything in our lives to accommodate
them or whoever it is that's being
sensitive and my thing is like your
sensitivity that's a you problem you
know it's a you problem it would be like
you go to a movie theater right you're
in a movie theater and the you come in
and you think that the the the volume is
too loud there's 500 people in this
movie theater and you're in there and
there's explosions and and and sounds
and you're just like oh my God this
movie theater is triggering me this is
too loud and then you go complain it's
too loud I mean everyone else is like
yeah we're good I like it loud uh we're
enjoying this movie see in that
situation that's a you problem if you're
the person that doesn't like loud noises
that's you that's all you leave get some
ear muffs but why why would we change
our whole thing for you right that's how
people are about this kind of stuff okay
like the lady has her own opinions and
ideas about whatever and you didn't you
heard something and you don't like it so
you want to come and speak first of all
you want to speak for all it's always
it's always white women you know that
like this the the gall of this person to
think that she's speaking for every
trans student on campus as if they're
all in Step they're all in line with
each other I I just I'm waiting to
see the trans people of color talking
like this publicly being like I'm
triggered I think if you're like already
a person of color you're already like
damn I'm already dealing with stuff and
now I'm adding that to it you're not
it's
like to me it's so it's so weird it's
like these white people who like have
been living a life of privilege let's
say and then all of a sudden now that
privilege is is has been challenged
because you've made this life choice and
they don't know how to handle it they're
like we're triggered how dare you and
like people of color are like yeah
welcome to America [__] this this is
what we've been dealing with so we have
to like pick ourselves up move forward
you know make something of ourselves
don't make excuses don't act like a
victim but it's like it seems to me that
like people that are experiencing this
for the first time they don't know how
to handle it so like I have an issue
with like you going to this event for
this person and being like uh you know
trying to make a scene and then she
handled it accordingly like bye you know
and it was another person who had the
same kind of thing it's just like now on
the other side of it I would say
this don't use I'm too pregnant for this
as your thing then you shouldn't be
doing public speaking if you're saying
I'm pregnant and my fuse is short well
then maybe you shouldn't be out on doing
doing Road tours cuz you know cuz then
you like out here making enemies so it's
just but hey more power to you it's her
choice she could do what she going to do
you know what I
mean but I just I really just have a
problem with like how we handle people's
sensitivities man you know it's like
these sensitivities are like it's a you
problem and when someone says to you say
you're being insensitive right like I I
unless someone you because you're
speaking about intent if you're saying
you go to somebody like especially when
it comes to Comedy right we up here just
doing jokes we're saying whatever we're
saying and we're assuming that people in
the crowd you you know you know what
they say about assuming but it's what we
do when you walk into a comedy club as a
comic you think well these people that
are coming they're going to be
open-minded I got to think they're going
to be open-minded and they have a
general understanding that these are
just jokes that we're trying to make
people laugh even if we're trying to
shock some Shock we're using it as a
tool for laughter that's really the
general idea of it right and so for
someone to be in a crowd and being like
hey oh my God you're being insensitive
it's like well wait a minute how do I
know what's going on with you that's a
you problem it's a you problem when no
I'm not being insensitive you're just
sensitive and so move leave you know
what I mean but to assume somebody's
intent now yes there are of course there
are cases where people are trying to be
insensitive I get that right but for the
most part I feel like that's not the
case for the most part I feel like
like we don't all have information about
everyone you know it's like I I don't
know if I've told this story before but
I used to have these jokes about you
know there was like this school shooting
in like Santa Barbara terrible thing it
was this guy he was like being rejected
by women and he shot up the place you
know and I I had this material about it
because I was I would be like hey guys
it was terrible and I'd be like I know
this is going to be hard for y'all to
believe but I too have been rejected by
women and I've never thought I need to
kill these [__] you know that's just
not how I dealt with it I would deal
with it it's like and then I just would
go on I was just talking about it in
that way of being like this guy had
issues but I remember the punch n of the
joke was like how sad this guy was and
and and and and I just want to say to
all the
women all the women that you rejected
him the way you
did excellent
choice you I mean obviously they were
right that's why they rejected him
because he has some crazy in him right
anyways I'm making a
point one day I'm at the Laugh Factory
and I do I'm doing this material and
then like I get off stage and I'm
killing the crowd the crowd was like in
it right the one of the waitresses comes
up to me and she's like you have to stop
doing that joke there's a girl in the in
the in the uh bathroom crying you know
and I was like what what so what I found
out later is this
girl she went she went to you to that
school and and she was there at this
time and she knew people right and so I
thought about that and I was like well
how would I know that so like am I being
insensitive or is she being sensitive
right and someone so like imagine
somebody attacking me being like I can't
believe you talked about that with that
it's like I don't know but let me tell
you this kudos to this girl cuz she
handled it the way you should handle it
she got up she left the room went to the
bathroom she cried she she was feeling
emotional and she had her emotions but
she did it on her own because that was
her thing it that was a her problem and
she dealt with it that way as opposed to
like like imagine she's in I'm doing
this and she's yelling out I can't
believe this you know you know and make
a whole thing when it was like the point
I was making was valid right and I tried
to put some humor on it and obviously a
bunch of a room full of people and the
majority of them was enjoying the way I
was addressing it but how do I know that
you know it's more sensitive to this
person like it's like when we're doing
comedy people want us to
um pass out a
clipboard you know pass out a clipboard
all right please fill out all the things
that trigger you before I go on stage
then I would be on stage with like you
know all the papers from everybody in
the audience I'd be like okay guys
before I start my set let me see what I
uh can't talk about you know I'll be
like oh okay wow all right don't make
jokes about this but I wouldn't be able
to talk about anything so just before
you start labeling somebody insensitive
just recognize that that sensitivity
that's a you problem a majority of the
time all right let's go on to the next
story um
[Music]
um I find this super interesting
California becomes the first US state to
ban Skittles and 12,000 additional
products for cancer-causing
additives I ain't always a fan of this
dude Nome but I'm a fan of this good for
you one day I was scouring the net and I
saw a list I gotta I wish I would have
found it for this episode but it was
like a list of like let's say it's
Skittles here and they had Skittles in
like England let's say right and you
look at the
ingredients there's far more ingredients
in ours than it is theirs like there's
cereals like basic things that we buy
that over there the the ingredients are
illegal that they've done their studies
and they're like now this stuff causes
cancer this stuff is like bad for your
health and there's so many things in
other countries where they go yeah we're
not putting this in our food that are in
our food so good for somebody finally
being like no sorry we're always talking
about big Pharma let's start talking
about you know big food or whatever the
whatever the term is for the like these
companies that just make stuff and they
put whatever they want in it and we're
out here just eating it if these things
even remotely cause cancer well good get
rid of them right I don't know this is
like what are we talking about it it's
like the fact that you know you know
what's crazy about you know our country
is we're always talking about like when
you're when you're labeled a conspiracy
theorist right it's like that dude you
know it's like Rob Robert Kennedy you
know they're always getting on him for
conspiracies and I was at the comic St
one night and I'm talking to somebody
and they're like well that guy says
crazy things and I was like what crazy
things has he said and they were like
well well the Wi-Fi okay the thing about
the Wi-Fi all right check this
out let's I it's not crazy to think that
we're using something in society that
could be bad for us you know what I mean
like if Skittles got cancer caus and
stuff in it that was the FDA or whoever
was like we're okay with this what if
WiFi is bad for our brains and it's
causing all these kind of issues it's
not like we haven't done that before
dude oxycotton was
approved it was approved it was like
people the doctors were selling it
people were getting rich people were
dying and we were just living our lives
like oh okay whatever that actually
happened there's A8 billion doll lawsuit
about it and that's not even enough it
should be more than that right we live
in a society where like you know where
where you know we had gas gasoline was
like you know it was like uh we were
getting five miles a gallon you know we
find oh you know what that's actually
not good for you good for the
environment or you you know uh emissions
and and and like you know it's like um
building building qualifications
building permits it's like you know in
our country like we build a building and
it has to have certain like earthquake
restrictions and all this kind of stuff
there's some countries that don't do
that and then like a a 6.5 earthquake
hits and freaking a thousand people die
because buildings collapse right that
kind of stuff happens all over the place
so why what I'm saying is I'm not going
to be surprised when it comes out that
Wi-Fi is bad for you I don't think it's
crazy because look at
this
12,000 additional products are because
of cancer-causing additives that's a lot
it's a lot okay that's a lot of products
that we were like n it's okay or
whatever the one product is that's in
all of these things that we're just kind
of like glossing over I'm just saying
it's like you know good for this guy
finally you know it's just like we we're
corporate greed is like that's a real
thing so I'm not going to be surprised
by anything as my
point all right new segment is I'm gonna
call this catching up with Britney
Spears
that's uh let me say it again new
segment on riffin with
Griffin catching up with Britney Spears
so this is one of Britney's latest
videos so for some reason she loves
dancing at this spot in her living
room what are we supposed to you know
it's a weird thing because it's like you
know there's so many schools of thought
so yeah let Britney live her life she
was in a she was in a a conservatorship
for 13 years and now she trying to get
get hers in right so there's that part
of it you know and we're just kind of
like okay whatever then there's like the
sexist uh War the sexist part of it it
was like you know it was a guy first of
all this is my thing about it if they if
this was like you know um like not I
would I don't even want to say Justin
Timberlake because he still looks like
Justin Timberlake you know what I mean
like whatever we liked about him he
still seems to have that but like I
don't know dude this is like like what
these like old bands or somebody you
know it's like when you see like Mickey
work and he does all that stuff to his
face you know when you see like a old
guy doing old doing stuff like to be
young you're like what are you doing man
it's like I don't know man this
just here's what this is what I was
thinking today I was talking about this
on my game stream I feel bad for her two
sons because they're like 15 they're
high school
age bro imagine you're in high
school and your mom is Britney
Spears
done like dunzo dude like how many times
did the teacher have to be like okay
guys enough I mean imagine you Britney's
kid you walk down the hallway and
somebody like is looking at your mom's
Instagram and they're like oops she did
it again y'all it's like you know what I
mean it's like is there any thought
about like you know this and this is
what sucks about her being in a
conservative ship for 13 years she
missed all that time to be like a crazy
her own craziness like just live your
life you know I'm 25 and I want to do
this and that she didn't even get to do
that cuz for 13 years her life was
locked up so now she doing it now but
I'm just like this looks crazy to me you
know this just
me like Britney what do you like just
for your kids don't do this I'mma about
to be a dad and I'm and now I'm thinking
oh my God like like what podcast
episodes will I have to take down you
know what I'm saying you just go but
you're not thinking about it cuz you're
living your own life and I'm just saying
she's living her own life now in this
sort of crazy lifestyle doing this kind
of stuff when it's like it's just weird
you know what I mean is am I am I am I
totally off bit if I am please put it in
the comments but I'm just like Britney
what are we
doing what are we doing you
know and and like and every every time
it's crazy I mean let's just recap from
last week too just just take a look at
it again
like it's
like out if you're you're in high
school
and you know you just we clown in high
school me and my friends used to clown
each other all the time B I was playing
basketball and we'd be going in and
imagine if you're in high school and
your friend's mom is Britney Spear
and you saw this knife
video dude these poor kids must be
getting
destroyed you know what I
mean I
mean these poor boys are just
like
H uh I don't know
I mean just like all the jokes that must
be happening every single day dude
oops oh yeah your mom's looking stronger
than
[Laughter]
yesterday you know what I'm saying it's
like you you be in class um um I have a
question
um you know is anything toxic
Maybe
you know it's just like I don't even
feel bad for her I feel bad for her
because of the conservatorship and and
everything she's gone through right you
know used as a show Pony for so many
years but Dan you got to feel bad for
her kids man you just have to
right all right guys all right it's time
guys spoiler alert time and this is the
time we've all been waiting for guys so
let's talk about it I was on a plane so
a couple years ago I was on a plane and
I saw Fast and the Furious 9 and it was
so
ridiculous that I was like I need to
talk about this on my podcast and as
you've known I've done a few times with
certain movies I just recap the movie
from beginning to
end so they're back the crew is back I
don't know what they do I'm not sure how
they went from Street Racers barbecuing
on their lawn in South Central to
International
spies I don't know when that
happened I'm not sure of the 10 movies
when this actually went happened but it
happened so this
movie Fast and Furious you know it stars
Vin Diesel Michelle Rodriguez Jason Stam
right who else is in this pad booy Jason
Statham Jordan Brewster Tyrese Gibson
ludicrous
uh like just Charlie ston you know Helen
mirin is in this Brie Larson is in this
uh what's her face the the Wonder
Woman's in it
it's like the list of people in this
movie you'd be like well damn this a lot
of good ass this a lot of good ass
people in this movie and so this one
also
had um what's his name
Jason Mamoa I always like to call him
Jason Mimosa so Jason Mimosa is in this
as the villain and he was actually my
favorite character in the movie because
he was playing this sort of like he was
playing this sort of weird bad guy
effeminate sort of like right there were
moments if you watch it you would be
like oh is is his character gay not that
there's anything wrong with it I'm just
saying he was making a choice you know
and I thought it was like I was like oh
okay good for you all right let's go
over this movie so first the description
of the
movie on
IMDb I really want to see
it um Dom Toretto and his family are
targeted by a vengeful son of a drug
kingpin Herman Reyes okay so the movie
opens up with a recap of a previous
shitty fast and and Furious movie I'm
not sure which one it was but it was the
one where at the end they're robbing a
bank and him and Paul Walker Vin Diesel
Paul Walker are driving two cars right
and they're pulling a safe through the
streets and this big metal safe like as
big as a room is just crashing around
the street you know wrecking cars almost
killing
people right so what they did was they
flashed back to this
movie and then they added new
scenes to make that movie even
shittier and then they added like so
they had this guy Herman rayz was like
this you know big Kingpin he was the the
B boss and then Jason MOA we're going to
call him Jason Mimosa for the rest of
the episode he so Mimosa he is the Son
and then so there's a whole thing you
know at the end of the big Climax and
that guy dies okay so they kill his
father in the car crash of trying to
escape with just safe with all this
money in it right because they at that
time they were B I don't know if they
were good guys or bad guys but they was
robbing people whatever I don't forgot
which dumb movie it was okay so then you
see Mimosa is upset and so now he
they've established that he's the bad
guy okay now open up the movie they had
Vin Diesel's house which I don't
understand why they still living in this
shitty house in in uh East LA like they
International spies they they you know
what I mean and they living at this
house in E that they've been living at
since movie one don't understand that
but it is what it is so then you know he
has a
son okay and he's living with Michelle
Rodriguez and they have this
relationship which I just don't believe
you know what I mean and now they're
also older and it's like you know we're
talking like this is almost 20 years
later and so they got this kid and you
know and so they and it's all this sort
of like really you know
melodramatic you know it's like it's all
about family and I'm not scared oh wait
sorry oh well let's go back so the movie
opens up with you know Mimosa you find
out the backstory of why he's not the
villain then the movie opens up on like
a car and the car is doing all this fast
and furious stuff you know it's jumping
around this parking lot it's you know
it's you know it's doing uh Donuts it's
doing all kind of weird stuff then you
come to find out that Vin Diesel's son
is driving the car
okay so I'm already out I'm out okay
anyways so he's taught him he's teaching
him how to be the new Vin Diesel you
know the new DA Toretto you know so you
know then again then they go back to the
house dramatic dramatic dramatic
dramatic dramatic you know it's like
they're you know they're always looking
at pictures of Paul Walker and I get it
rip um you know and then Charlie ston
shows up and she's been the bad guy in
like eight of the movies I think well in
a lot of the movies Sharice Theon has
been like this bad guy who like runs
this secret Tech organization this like
you know and they can like hack anything
and what ever so she's been the leader
of this and she's like on the on their
list cuz she like killed somebody
special I don't remember who I think it
was his W his ex-wife or like the mo
mother of the kid I don't even know who
she killed but she killed somebody so
then she shows up at the house with a
bullet wound she's all injured you know
and then it's like so then Dom and uh
Michelle Rodriguez are like okay what
are you doing here and she's got like a
gun with a silencer you know at at the
house in East at
right and then sh Ton's like okay you
know the enemy of my enemy is my friend
and she's like we have a common foe you
know and then it's she she tells the
story of how she met Jason Mimosa you
know and he comes to her like secret
Dojo where she got all her Tech stuff
and all the guns and then he's all like
being real like flamboyant he's
flamboyant as [__] in this movie and
he's like telling all the bad guys so
she got all these henchmen pointing guns
at him and then he flips it on her
because he's like he knows everybody's
name and he's like yeah you you know
Bobby I know you and I know your your
wife's beautiful and and you Larry your
kids and so then they all get text
messages at the same time and all their
families are being kidnapped okay so
which is like ridiculous okay like if
you a henchman you know you get henchmen
and they all have families like like
what did what henchman
like so you got a wife and kid
you got a wife and kid at home and you
decide to join with the
Evil
Underground underground crazy [__] that
wants to take over the world and you got
a wife and kid at home what are we
talking about anyways so they all turn
on her right and then of course she's
like a badass ninja and
she beats up all her people and escapes
and now cut back that was the the
flashback now we cut to here we are at
the same time that this is happening
okay Tyrese and ludicrous they off on a
mission in Spain or
someplace Rome that that Tyrese's
character has like you know Roman is you
know and he's like the dummy of the
group so he somehow got this Mission and
they're going to go steal something a
secret whatever right and then they go
on this Mission come to find out the
mission is it's fake it's a setup by
Mimosa so Jason Mimosa set him up right
so they on this Mission and so Dom and
Michelle Rodriguez realized uhoh they
can't get a hold of them so they got to
go and stop this you know because they
so then now they're driving this truck
right so the they they're gonna Rob this
truck because it's got like I don't know
some kind of something on it you know
one of those movie plot things where
they got to steal this to save the world
type of [__] so they get into truck
it's all this big and first of all I
didn't understand that they're on this
secret mission and ludicrous is wearing
a starter jacket and the other girl
she's wearing like is this everybody
stylish as [__] on this secret mission
anyways so so somehow they end up in
this truck the door's locked now the
truck's being driven remotely by the bad
guy and the bad guy's got a bomb in it
and this bomb and he's he's heading it
this truck towards the Vatican because
he's going to blow up the Vatican and
blame it on Dom and his people because
Dom killed his father so he wants to
make Dom suffer so he's not going to
kill him he's going to kill
everybody he's going to like kill
everybody in the family first right make
everybody suffer so now they trying to
get out of this truck with this bom and
of course Dom shows up in a muscle car
that's got like James Bond [__] on it
okay which I I don't know how that
happened okay so he's got like you know
all kinds of gizmos and gadgets on this
car so then the
bomb gets out of the truck and it's like
a big ball and the truck this bomb
starts rolling down the street so
then Dom sees that the ball he's in the
car and he sees that the ball's about to
like Crush some people and then he like
puts the car like he's controlling the
bomb with his car banging over things
and jumping over stuff and this bomb is
just wrecking through the streets and
then it also catches on fire and it's
headed towards the Vatican okay so
now so the D's driving and so the bomb's
about to blow up at the Vatican but then
there's like a river and there's like a
freaking you know you know what I mean
there's like a bridge and so and then
there's like a crane there's a crane
over the bridge because they doing some
work so don takes his car right and he
goes with the car real fast and somehow
with his car he hits the crane okay and
then the crane swings around and hits
the big bomb and the bomb goes into the
river and blows up okay so Dom saves the
day with this incredible car maneuver
you know what I mean how many muscle
cars does this [__] have okay
anyway so they saved the day but then
like they've been set up so now they're
Public Enemy Number One again you know
as if the the agents the agency you know
like they don't know who they are at
this point they've been working with
them and all this stuff so now there's
like a new head of the agency and then
like you know so the one girl who's
father was played by uh who was it
played by um you the tango and cash guy
you know Mr Nobody that was his name on
the thing his daughter is now in charge
but then she's not in charge of this
part of the agency so she goes to the
agency and then there's a guy there
who's like that's it we're going after
him you know so this guy's like we're
gonna get Dom tetto you know what I mean
I'm like I which is ridiculous to me
because for 10 for like 20 years now
this [__] has been saving the
United States from all kinds of stuff
and now all of a sudden after one thing
you're not going to give him the benefit
of the doubt that was dumb could have
suspend my disbelief for that so now the
agency's after him too
right so they they capture Michelle
Rodriguez and they take her to a black
site I don't know why this one Mexican
woman needs to
be taken to a black site in Antarctica
okay which is like
okay all right okay so
then people just keep showing up Helen
mirin show just shows up you know and
Helen mirin is Jason stm's mother in
this movie which I don't know why I
don't know how that's significant you
know uh you know so then now they have
to like try to stop Jason you know
Mimosa you know and he's just like this
real flamboyant character so then Jason
Mimosa shows back up so then you know
he's like taunting Dom the whole time
and then they meet up at like a street
racing thing and then of course this is
the now this is Fast and the Furious
again so there like everybody's got guns
and they're pointing at each other and
you know and Dom's like let's finish
this you know and then mimosa's like
well let's
Race So this this guy blew up the
[__] Vatican almost right and they go
street race okay so now they street race
and then you know and then like one of
the girls that's street racing is like
somehow related to DM I don't know how
whatever so Mo MOS is letting Dom know
I'mma kill one of them so they go on
this ridiculous street race where what
the guy one of the guys that was like
running the street race you know his car
blows up he dies but then Dom somehow
okay so there's a bomb on the bottom of
this girl's car right and I don't know
how Dom knew the bomb was at the bottom
of the car he hits her car he hits her
in the car and then her car somehow
turns like this and and and then the
bomb gets hit off I don't know anyways
he rescues
her so now Dom's even more incentify to
go get this kid so now Mimosa says to
him I'm going to get your kid so then
then oh you know who shows up um what's
the dude that speaks [__] he speaks
Chinese you know he was in um what is
this dude's name there's so many people
in this movie I gotta find his name on
the list because I forgot his name um I
don't even know look Pete Davidson was
in this this this is crazy what's the
guy's name dude um he was in that good
great
show you know the guy that got in
trouble with China and he was speaking
in China he's on oh John Cena
so John Cena is there too so John Cena
okay so then now they sent a hit team to
get Dom son okay and then John Cena
shows up and of course he beats up
everybody and takes the kid and they go
you know to a meeting place okay all
right so I'mma cut to the
end so then we come to find out you know
they go they go arrest Don Dom finally
gets arrested you know he's on a bridge
and he gets arrested they they meet up
with mimosa and you know they have this
big fight the thing but then a
helicopter comes and starts killing
people cuz Mimosa got resources out of
the wazu right so they on a bridge and
they having this big fight you know and
then uh Dom rescues this girl the girl
again the girl again and then Brie
Larson is there too by the way Captain
Marvel's there she gets shot I I don't
even know what her whole thing was I
don't know why that [__] was even
around at the same time you know she has
to go to the black side in Antarctica to
tell Michelle Rodriguez I'm going to try
to but I'm bust you out of jail and then
Michelle Rodriguez and um sh ston who
are like bitter enemies they had to like
work together to escape so they gonna
forgive her all the [__] she did so they
escaping this Antarctic prison okay then
they find a then they like run into
somebody who got a submarine like it's
all
ridiculous and the submarine people
picked them up whatever so now we cut
back to they trying Mimosa is trying to
get Dom's son okay you know
and so John Cena takes the kid to this
like I don't know some desert Outpost
with they that they have and they have
some ridiculous car with two cannons on
it which is ridiculous so then like you
know 50,000 enemies show up of mimosas
to capture the kid so they trying to
escape you know what I mean so they in
this car and they blowing up cars it's a
it's a stupid car you know what I mean
he's like got big cannons on it and then
the thing gets jammed right so they
trying to get away but at the same time
on the bridge oh when Dom get arrested
on the bridge right he's on the bridge
he's going to get arrested and when he's
getting arrested he's like he's holding
his he's holding his fist and he's just
like he's always walking like he's
He-Man and like they don't put cuffs on
this [__] or nothing he's the
most wanted man in the world and they
just let him walk into a van with no
nothing no shackles nothing and then
he's all in the van like you better hold
on and they're like what you know what
are you talking about then of course a
missile comes and blows up the thing and
then you know and now the the the the
the head of the the agency got
he's like oh I believe you now Dom and
they're having a gunfight gunfight
gunfight you know what I mean and then
like you know you know they they escape
and then of course Dom has a car he has
his black car again you know and so the
plane comes down because all these
people are coming after John Cena and
the kid so John Cena's driving this car
with the kid and there's like 75 cars
behind him trying to get him you know
what I mean he's blowing him up you know
and then Mimosa comes and he's got his
car I don't know why he has a old muscle
car too for some [__] reason and he's
he he's driving after John Cena and the
kid right so then the kid is trying to
like help so the kid gets out of the car
in while the car is moving on the
freeway and he goes to unjam the the
rocket launcher okay so while the kid is
on the back of the car in a rocket
launcher Mimosa drives up and snatches
the kid from the back and puts him in
his car okay so now John Cena's like oh
[__] Dom he's got Brian what are we
going to
do so then of course you know uh you
know Dom's in his like black muscle car
and then two helicopters come right two
helicopters come and shoot two uh Arrows
with with on ropes and and and um
anchors into his car so these two
helicopters are flying and trying to
stop but of course the muscle car is
stronger than two helicopters and he
somehow does a maneuver that makes the
helicopters crash into each other and
blow up and now he's dragging the
helicopters behind him right and then he
does like a you know he does like this
move that crashes into Mimosa but Mimosa
is still going right anyways so mimosa's
you know he you know he gets past all
that and so he goes and he's grabbed
he's got the kid in his car and then
Dom's in his car chasing him because
he's he's like I'm gonna kill your kid
right and then like he's got the
microphone like the the the the the
radio right and then Dom tells like some
secret message to his son remember what
I said about such and such doing some
such and such had of such and such time
you you're my kid boom boom boom and so
then you know you know oh he knows so
this is the most ridiculous [__] ever
Dom takes his car somehow hits that car
the other car that mimosa and his kid
are in while that happens the cars turn
at the exact time Vin Diesel cracks open
his door the door to the other car opens
and he goes now and then the
and then the kid jumps
out the kid jumps out of the car while
they're spinning and he flies into Dom's
car and it's like yeah it is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever seen on a in
a movie so then now they on a now he
gets his kid back and they're on a a dam
and he stops in the middle of this Dam
and then two gas trucks are which are
being remot controled by Mimosa cuz he
survived you know cuz Dom like somehow
got the helicopter and flew it hit him
with the helicopter you know and so you
know Mimosa is like did you hit me with
a helicopter that was so cool because
he's such a flamboyant character right
he's like it's not over enough games now
it's time to die so he sends these two
so Dom's at the top of a dam okay in his
black muscle car with his kid in the car
and these two gas trucks are headed
towards his car at the top and then you
know what I mean and then he has the
line of the movie you made one
mistake you let me get in a
[Laughter]
car so then he puts pedal to the m pedal
to the metal and he crashes over the
side of the dam the two trucks explode
there's gas everywhere there's a huge
explosion and then D diesel is jumping
off the van this and he he's on the damn
now with his St in the car the car is on
fire he hits the Nitro and they freaking
jump you know what I mean with his kid
in the car and they crash into the water
right and then they get out of the water
you know and they're like yeah but it's
and somehow the radio survives and
mimosa's like oh it's not over time to
die and then you see that the the
dam has got all these explosions and Dom
and his kid are down there oh and by the
way so there was a plane where Tyrese
and everybody is coming back from Rome
to come help Dom rescue him and then the
guy that was the head of the agency
turns out to be a bad
guy he rocket launchers their plane and
then their plane goes off you don't see
what happens to
them so the movie
ends with Vin Diesel and his kid at the
bottom of this
Dam and explosion the Dam's about to
blow up and then they go Fade to Black
and you now know that's going to be fast
x 2 which is supposed to be the end of
the
franchise
uh I'm telling you
man
I hope you enjoyed that because that was
without a
doubt just I mean one of the most
ridiculous ridiculous
scenes that I've really ever seen in a
movie but shout out to Vin Diesel man
who's probably a billionaire making 10
movies over 20 year span with this
franchise it's super entertaining it's
like a guilty pleasure really but man
it's terrible I mean terrible like
everybody
like terrible but anyways y'all y'all
know what time it is I want to thank
everybody for watching the show uh make
sure you hit the Subscribe button you
know twitch I'm on Twitch always and if
you want to be a you know remember hit
me up on the patreon and you know what
what time it
is uh with that rap
recap ooo got I'm
back uh got that podcast World on my
back that's a
fact woo Skittles are whack oh B
Skittles it's no
riddles Frizzle
dles catching balls like kles
woo fast
X it was the
best
not can't believe I got
[Music]
got everybody listen I got to go but
thanks for being here as always Griffin
with Griffin your favorite
podcast if you have a movie You' like me
to watch movie you like me to see let me
know and you know
I might do real world advice from a
grown ass man next week but thanks for
being here and I will see you next
week